and so we started thinking about using
iot sensors in summer of 19 we
discovered that most businesses didn't
have sensors deployed inside
Refrigeration because Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth couldn't get a signal out
reliably this the fridge or the freezer
had a side with iron or steel or
aluminum and the side of the fridge of
the freezer blocked Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
signals so we started thinking about
maybe we can solve that and improve on
that we developed a new type of
connectivity where we used a new type of
connectivity protocol a long-range radio
to develop a solution that uses radio as
opposed to Wi-Fi and Bluetooth so our
sensors use Laura long-range radio to
push signal out of the inside of
refrigeration
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders meet Monique Suri Monique is
founder and CEO of Therma a technology
startup whose mission is to help protect
our food health and planet
Therma build safety and sustainability
tools to eliminate food waste improve
Energy Efficiency and reduce refrigerant
emissions protecting consumers and
combating climate change Therma is
deploying across the restaurants
retailers Distributors and manufacturers
worldwide with leading Brands including
McDonald's Starbucks NOW Foods 7-Eleven
and Marriott Hotels
previously Monique co-founded the
governance lab and Innovation Center at
NYU that develops Technology Solutions
to improve government he has been
recognized amongst the top 100 Harvard
alumni in technology a past affiliate of
Harvard's Berkman Center for internet
and society and previously held
positions at Global investment firm D.E
Sean company and the White House
National Economic Council
[Music]
I'm so excited to a Garner even more
inspiration and now that we're talking
you're the CEO of Therma and after some
some really amazing experiences and
education and some of the best places in
the world and and you chose to spend so
much of your time and effort dealing
with sustainability and dealing with
something that the world really needs
your your product is operating in more
than 5 000 restaurants looking at iot
devices and how do we manage uh
information within our food ecosystem
and how do we know what's happening
behind the scenes so that things don't
go straight so I'm excited to dive into
your own Journey as well as that of
thermals and understand sort of what is
it that you care about and how you solve
it so money tell me a little bit about
sort of your entrance to the
entrepreneurial world how did you
discover food waste and iot as something
that is deeply important to you
I appreciate the question and definitely
something uh you know I think about now
never imagined I'd be working in
refrigeration and and the food supply
chain I think
um The Journey was uh you know kind of a
long path series of twists of turns as
life often is I started working on uh
policy uh right out of law school so in
college I thought I was going to study
uh political science and go and work in
government I ended up
um going to work in the private sector
for a few years at a big hedge private
Equity Fund was an investor then went
back to law school uh went to work in
government doing economic policy in the
Obama White House and
um you know I discovered or learned
about the space around tech for good
partly through a colleague of mine there
was a woman I was working with Beth
Novick she was the deputy CTO in the
first Obama administration she had also
opted in law school and she jokes a
recovering lawyer uh
and uh she read she'd written a book
called Wiki go uh the Wiki government
basically the idea was that technology
was transforming so much of Life are we
dying how we date how we engage in
everyday activity but law and government
and big public problems were still being
sold like it's 1950 and so the idea
behind the book was that hey you could
build Tech to solve some of these big
problems that were broken
and help improve sectors like regulation
compliance and government so I read the
book I listened to Beth's talk made a
lot of sense it was really inspired this
is 10 years ago and I decided to join
her uh instead of going to work in
government I left and when she left
government we started a center together
at NYU and MIT where she teaches called
the governance lab or gov lab so that
was how it got into Tech and the idea
that one could deploy Network and data
tools to solve problems uh that have
significant social impact that was
always something interesting to me
um coming from a family that was largely
service oriented my parents are both
doctors three of my grandparents are
doctors uh so I had a lot of
um service in my culture and family
culture so to speak there was always
this idea that should do something with
your life that's more than just you know
making your own situation better
um and so sustainability was not a
problem I thought a lot about it as a
kid I first heard about climate change
in the 90s and I thought it was about
the ozone layer getting depleted uh yeah
Vincent skin cancer and then encourage
this
um you know this famous movie came out
um called Inconvenient Truth by Al Gore
um and I went and heard him talk he gave
it talked at Harvard when I was an
undergrad
um wow movie but I thought his son was
actually a classmate of my algor Jr was
a classmate of mine in college but I
thought that on Senator Gore's book um
and the movie was really about a problem
for the Future these were like problems
that like 100 years from now people
would have to worry about
and I grew up in California largely in
Northern California a couple hours
outside uh San Francisco in the east in
the Central Valley and I thought
um you know sustainability was a problem
at most in the developing world but more
recently in the last kind of six years
uh living in in San Francisco I started
to experience some of this stuff
firsthand
um there were wildfires in Napa a couple
of years ago one of the worst ever in
the state and I was staying up there
with my wife we got on vacation we
actually evacuated in the middle of the
night wow and drove through the
wildfires with fire around wow so it's
18 fire trucks went by us I mean at 2
A.M my parents evacuated twice in Fresno
California there were wildfires 35 miles
from our house where I grew up
um and it seemed kind of sustainability
get worse and worse not just in the kind
of news but also in California where I
live and amongst many people I knew it
became a top that people started talking
about every year oh it's Fire season oh
my God there's a drought there's you
know lots of problems here but you know
this one
um you know around uh the growing
urgency became one that I saw firsthand
and so I guess
there was a combination of
intellectually knowing it was a big
problem uh discovering it for the first
time myself as a person living in
Northern California and traveling around
and seeing it in the you know in the
land around us and then also I think
from a technology standpoint when I was
working on dogs lab we discovered that
there was an opportunity to work on
compliance and improve safety and
sustainability in the food industry and
so it's been working on food back in
2015 around the time that chipotle was
having a series of issues with um
remember and we started scaling um the
precursor to Therma a product called
co-inspect and realized that a lot of
the problem that businesses had was
around managing temperature and all
these perishables that they had these
inventory were getting spoiled or thrown
out or lost and wasted and when I
started studying and researching food
waste
I didn't realize it was this bigger
problem I had no idea uh that a bunch of
drawn down one of the non-profit
studying global warming says it's the
you know fourth largest cause of global
warming which is just crazy that uh whoa
really I have to understand that better
how is it the fourth largest cause well
what is it what is it the you know food
waste poor Refrigeration in inaccuracies
why is that such a huge problem yeah I
mean I think it's partly because
everyone eats um so there's a lot of
food in the world the supply chain is
pretty large it moves trillions of
dollars worth of inventory every year
part of it is that we're just so
inefficient we waste so much of what we
produce apparently we waste around 33
percent of all the food we made which is
like an astounding number that's like
wow one out of every three pounds of
food that's made is thrown away
um and you know when you think about
that at scale given that we feed nine
billion humans
um you know I guess food waste as a
country would be like the fourth largest
emitter and you know the amount of land
mass that's needed to grow that much
food is like the size of all of
Australia the entire continent of
Australia so it's just a it's just a
large and broken uh problem because the
supply chain and the way in which food
is consumed and sold has so much
inefficiency in it refrigeration is One
Source it's not the only part of the
problem sure it's one of the sources of
waste cold chain or cold refrigeration
supply chain is not available
a lot of the energy and a lot of the
um resources have already gone into
making it so if you're throwing product
out right before people consume it so
much has already gone into getting it
there that steak or that Sushi or that
protein or that Dairy is getting thrown
out in the restaurant or the comedian
store it's just uh it's extremely
wasteful when you think about it from
how much resourcing has gone into
getting it there and getting it grown
and so we're trying to catch and reduce
the storage and handling portion of the
food waste problem that's only one of
the drivers but it's um it's a
significant driver and so
um that's kind of the skill at 1.6
trillion uh dollars worth of food thrown
out every year nine percent in storage
and handling that's the 150 billion that
we're going after with Derma incredible
take me back to those founding days the
coming up with you know in hindsight
makes perfect sense great thesis a lot
you know it makes it's perfectly clear
it can it couldn't have been that easy
to unfold and uncover from the get-go
what was sort of your own ideation
process slide because you're also coming
from a legal background and you know you
you get an entrance to Tech you realize
that you can use tech for good there's
sustainability that's actually a big
problem and how do you actually combine
all that to come up with an
entrepreneurial thesis as a CEO so yeah
it's definitely it's a journey you know
these things are iterative the first
idea we had in um in starting out to
build tech for good in the food supply
chain was around compliance and safety
we were trying to help eliminate uh
problems around uh food safety and
quality by replacing pen and paper log
books with a mobile app that was our
first product co-inspect collaborative
inspect mobile app with structured data
and ability used to timestamp and catch
you know and monitor stuff digitally
instead of a clipboard we scaled that to
a few thousand locations and we
discovered that most of what people were
checking was the temperature
and so in the summer of 2019 we were
watching users using this mobile app our
first product and we realized that we
weren't solving the problem that well we
were replacing a paper clipboard with a
digital supports but they still had to
do this work every day so they were
going from doing it on a piece of paper
to doing it on the mobile app or a
tablet
and so that's what we started thinking
well they don't really want to check
this out they're busy they've got a lot
of stuff going on and making them do it
four times a day or eight times a day in
some locations is still very inefficient
what if we could automate it what if we
could use sensors to replace the work
entirely and make it continuous and so
we started thinking about using iot
sensors in summer of 19 we discovered
that most businesses didn't have sensors
deployed inside Refrigeration because
Wi-Fi and Bluetooth couldn't get a
signal out reliably this the fridge or
the freezer had a side with iron or
steel or aluminum and the side of the
fridge the freezer blocked Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth signals so we started thinking
about maybe we can solve that and
improve on that we developed a new type
of connectivity where we used a new type
of connectivity protocol a long range
radio to develop a solution that uses
radio as opposed to Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
so our sensors use Laura long-range
radio to push signal out of the inside
of refrigeration as we started putting
these sensors in the world
two and a half years ago in late 19 we
discovered that we were helping
businesses Monitor and catch
Refrigeration failure and by doing that
you're helping them reduce waste and
reduce spoilage and so we kind of
stumbled into the problem around food
waste because we were working on helping
businesses catch and monitor
refrigeration and replacing pen and
paper first for the mobile app and then
with sensors and so we discovered that
Refrigeration monitoring mattered a lot
to them because they wanted to reduce
waste and also wanted to reduce
Refrigeration downtime that's another
big source of emissions Refrigeration
has these chemicals inside call
refrigerants well when they leak in the
atmosphere they cause a lot of global
warming their Ultra warming chemicals
and so by monitoring Refrigeration we
were helping businesses reduce food
waste and in some cases reduce
refrigerants and so we really discovered
wow we're working on a climate problem
this is n19
um and that's that's when we started
scaling so Thermo went from you know 100
sensors so now over 10 000 a couple of
customers now over a thousand customers
and so now we're growing but we kind of
you know
stumbled into it if you will
now if you're if you're looking at this
company is this a you know it's sort of
it's a very impact impact first you know
type of company was that from the get-go
is that what you knew that you were
going to position a company that has a
very impact-oriented Vision rather than
a business oriented Vision because they
they do go hand in hand but always sort
of there's there's an intent component
to it that you as an entrepreneur need
to bring to the table so you know back
then and today are you with the same
intent and what intent is that yeah we
are uh always and I think we have always
been interested in the impact side Aaron
my co-founder and I kind of decided to
work together first at the gov lab and
then when we left to start coincidence
we wanted to work on Tech that had some
kind of social uh significance that
really solved major public problems and
the problems we were looking at were
problems that we felt the private sector
wasn't solving wealth so they were
originally around compliance and safety
and then increasingly around climate and
sustainability but the idea of helping
the food supply chain uh was really
designed around okay this is an area
that's both very inefficient where
businesses waste and lose a lot of money
and also one that we can do some good
that's been important to me since you
know 10 years ago when I got into temp
and I left government and that's partly
I think what brought me and Aaron
together both at the gov lab and then
now you know as entrepreneurs
now I can imagine going to restaurants
and selling them you know different iot
devices for their kitchen I imagine that
a lot of kitchens still today are pretty
low Tech in nature and they're very
human oriented
what was the receptivity of
customers I mean obviously have more
than a thousand different customers so
so the reception is good but what was
sort of the relationship that you were
feeling with customers as you were first
rolling this out and testing yeah well I
think we certainly had a lot of empathy
for our customers and a lot of
experience because of coinspect we'd
been working in the food industry for
three years we've been scaling and
selling into food
manufacturers Food Distributors and you
know food service and Retail so we had
gotten to know and spent a lot of time
with restaurant owner operators uh you
know Food Service owner operators food
manufacturers I think I went to 40
States
um doing skills and meeting corporates
and the dewormer three times McDonald's
store books toys Wendy's corporate
Denny's corporate Choice I've been in a
lot of places that I'd never been to
when I went to Harvard for college and
law school and certainly very different
parts of the country but I think what we
discovered with Irma was that we were
solving a problem that was saving
businesses money in a way that was very
measurable we were catching
Refrigeration equipment failure that was
helping them reduce asset replacement
and asset repair and helping them reduce
food spoilage and that's measurable
those are dollars that they need and so
even though we started selling Therma at
a really tough time we started selling
Therma in early 2020. well you might
remember a couple of books yeah the
world literally fell apart covid showed
up in restaurants and hospitality and
Retail companies were not exactly having
an easy time so the fact that we grew at
3x in 2020 and again 3x and 21 was not
easy but I think what we discovered is
we were solving a problem that
businesses cared about and it created
real Roi for them it really saved their
money we also did it in a way that was
easy to deploy our solution requires
about 15 minutes to set up there's no
technician no installation it's a drop
in place solution you hold up our mobile
app you label the sensors and you're
done and so and we don't charge for
hardware and we don't charge for
implementation it's a pure SAS model
it's an entirely subscription-based so
solving a problem that's measurable that
saves them money where the installation
is easy where there's not a lot of
friction and on top of that having it be
a climate way having it be a
sustainability win that combination has
made it attractive for big businesses
and small and so I've been very excited
that we've been able to sign up you know
operators of McDonald's Pizza Hut
Domino's Taco Bell Starbucks Burger King
Wendy's and a bunch of others and a
bleach of Independence we've got food
trucks uh mom and pop pizzerias three
location scoop shops independent
breweries you know these are really
folks that are not super well resourced
they don't have huge budgets and so I'm
really proud of that because I always
wanted to build tech for good but also
may get accessible to people you know
regardless of whether you're Vic
conglomerate or a small independent and
um yeah I guess the last thing I'll say
about that like was I grew up in a form
town I grew up in an AG town called
Fresno
um that's why I really had forums behind
my house we had like walled Orchards
literally behind my home I think I
always had this appreciation for the
food industry uh that it's it's it's
important
um and it's everywhere you know we need
food as one of the pillars of of modern
society but it's kind of one of those
areas that's considered unsexy you know
most most people I know don't want to
think about it or don't really spend a
lot of time worrying about how we get
stuff from Farm to Ford you know uh in
places like San Francisco and New York
you know you like eating fancy food and
good food but you don't have to think
about how it gets there and so I guess
I've always had this kind of personal
interest and appreciation just because I
knew a lot of Growers and a lot of AG
I love it how do you get a thousand
restaurants to hear about you well what
is it you know I'm coming from the deep
Tech scene a lot of SAS companies you
know there's different you know go to
market strategies that I could do that I
could think of but how do you go and
create and sell a product probably one
of the first iot devices that a lot of
restaurants uh put into their kitchens
how do you go and and and get it even in
front of their eyes so that they can
realize that they can not only make the
world you know say full ways but they
can also save money along the way
definitely something I spend a lot of
time thinking about because now we're
trying to get you know from ten thousand
to a hundred thousand sensors
um I think there's a few different
things that have worked well for us one
is
um e-commerce and and online we've
actually had really good success with
digital marketing and content so we we
Market it and and advertise on uh
platforms like Facebook LinkedIn
Instagram
uh Google of course uh and so the you
know the reality is a lot of our uh
buyers and a lot of our customers are
digital natives or are at least checking
out technology digitally before buying
and so e-commerce has been a great way
for us to drive
um you know traffic and to uh Roi or
landing pages with case studies or with
testimonials where people can say oh
that's a business like mine oh that's a
win that technology might be applicable
it's also a really low friction way to
get to people it doesn't require a lot
of you know uh massive capital
investment and then we also have a
traditional model we have a direct sales
team our direct sales team includes um
you know folks that are doing uh lead
generation we've got people that are
attending conferences we go to about a
dozen conferences a year uh we do boom
well uh we fly around the country I told
you I've been to a lot of States
um we definitely uh do some outfoundland
field selling for larger accounts
um that's what I think it was a
traditional direct sales model so we've
got an e-commerce digital marketing
driven go to market and then a direct
sales uh and now we're starting to
pursue Channel Partners so now we're
starting to work with some distribution
uh internal partners that are looking to
resell or cross-sell technology like
ours that might have much larger armies
a much larger Footprints customers and
we're starting to work with them as
partners but yeah those are kind of the
three ways for go to market
my name I love what you're doing
with uh with Therma I I love even more
the journey that you're talking about
you know going from one path in life
from one area to all of a sudden
discovering this new this new vertical
and discovering technology and
technology for good in the golf lab and
and then looking at that climate and
going back to college and and figuring
okay this is this makes sense with what
I learned there and now I can actually
leverage this for for restaurants and
and build them some product but actually
I'm stumbling onto something even
greater that actually serves the purpose
of of what I got excited about tech in
the first place and now I can actually
build a big massive company and I 150
billion dollar industry so a awesome
Journey I'm sorry that I left some
pieces out in the summarization but but
that's what come on and it's a it's a
really inspiring Journey so thank you
very very much and uh best of luck with
Therma I'm gonna continue cheering from
the side and uh thank you very much my
pleasure thanks for the kind words
um if you want to check it out
hellotherma.com feel free to reach out
to me Monica hello therma.com thanks for
having me Michael